a frog goes into a bank to get a loan so
the Frog goes up to the lady and she has
a little nametag on as they do it says
whack so her name is mrs. whack so can I
get a loan I don't know you're a frog
well I want a loan what's your name
Kermit you're not missing the Frog no no
no I was named after him the name is
Kermit Jagger my father's Mick Jagger
and my mother's a frog he [ __ ] a frog
and I'm his offspring well anyways I
want alone for a lily pad well you can't
I don't know if you can happen do you
have any collateral well I have this the
Frog pulls out a little shiny pink
elephant you know a little shiny pink
elephant so mrs. whack looks at it and
her name is patty I don't think this is
much collateral you know but I'll talk
to the bank manager about it you know
it's a frog out there Kermit Jagger gave
me this damn thing did you know I have
any idea what this is
the bank manager says what is this this
is a knick-knack patty-whack give the
Frog alone his old man's a rolling stone
I do my girl took me to a street fair
recently right you know they closed off
the block there's like shwarma there's
like stuff made out of buttons right
people know tithi making key chains
right
typical girlfriend idea it sucks and
it's gonna take all Saturday right
no we show up right the first thing she
sees is this big table nothing but
homemade jewelry right homemade jewelry
it's got twigs macaroni in it it's just
it's a table of crap it's crap
the whole thing is crap but she loves it
she's like oh my god look at these
earrings do you like these do you think
these are nice I just want to be like no
they were nicely they'd be in a store
all right
but I don't want to ruin a so my dad
check it up I'm gonna go get some air
you can / outside I think there's more
air right so I walked like three floor
tables away and I come up to this lady
she got this big table and nothing but
muffins muffins right it's like 85
degrees out she's selling muffins and
she's got this big stupid look at the
muffins I made look in her face and the
second I saw that that part of my brain
was just like dude what would happen if
you just walked up and just said hey
lady
these your muffins oh yeah they just
started going
my company these muffins could I mush
before anybody did anything I mean
realistically I think I could have got
the whole tape
cuz even if you saw me doing that it
would take at least five to six seconds
to process like did they say to do that
like a game to eat the muffin off your
face that just seems like a waste of
pastry you know there's no security at a
street fair there's no bouncer staying
there he's pushing the muffins ok I'm on
it sir
hook me up so I just started thinking of
the horrified look on this lady's face
as I started slamming these muffins and
out of nowhere I just started laughing
like a maniac
they slumped over this fried dough card
I'm dying my girl looks at me she's like
what the hell are you laughing at
and like an idiot I actually tried to
explain rude um thought to her my god
just sit there like I was just a kid
what if I started punching the muffins
you start punching them just looking at
me like why do I go out with you
whoo but I swear to God if I never broke
eye contact the second I started hitting
those muffins that lady she wouldn't
even been able to call for help I would
have been in don't understand it my
first week in the building about a year
ago I went down to the courtyard for the
first time and I didn't look too good
you know as a Sunday morning that's my
least presentable hour a lot of you know
just stains just like you know food and
me and whatever and so I'm sitting I'm
sitting there so shut up
Oh anyway but so there I was I'm sitting
on the stone bench of this courtyard and
feeling a little out of place you know
there's these fancy doormen and stuff
and then there's this guy looking at me
I noticed he's looking at me from across
the courtyard and he's all spiffy
looking he's got brown shoes and he's
looking at me like hmm I could tell he
was thinking I don't live in the
building he thinks I just wandered in
off the streets and sat in a courtyard I
can tell he's thinking of coming over
and dealing with me on his own and I'm
sitting there thinking like oh please do
that yes please come on come I come I
got Michael in and I'm trying to look
even more gross like my shirt and then I
see him gone no that's not gonna do it
all and he comes over to me hmm
and I'm like so excited to have this
thing
the confrontation where I'm not wrong at
all
and he thinks I am so he comes over says
excuse me do live in this building
and I said no cuz why not start there
I said no he goes well then what are you
doing here and I said I just need to
rest him having a hard time he says this
is private property and I said well I
don't really believe in that you know
just the worst things I could say from
his point of view it's basically all the
things I was saying and he goes well if
you don't leave I'm gonna talk to the
doorman I was like can I just stay like
five more hours so he's known he goes
over to the doorman and I see him
talking about me to the doorman like
this and then I see the doorman going oh
no that guy lives here that's okay
and the look on his face it was just so
it was this beautiful cocktail of anger
and confusion it's like I had an
invented a new way to hurt somebody's
feelings that's that's how excited I was
he was so eager he came back came back
to me said why didn't you tell me that
you lived here and I said because I
don't have to tell you anything ever
there are no words that I must say to
you all so I didn't want to ruin your
thing that's your favorite thing you
were doing
making people not be places also I make
more than you I just don't give a [ __ ]
about myself anyway
he didn't say anything after that
because well the whole thing didn't
really happen
I mean well it's it's not true but it
says it's as true as anything that does
happen I mean really anytime anybody
says anything to me I decide what they
said anyway but the truth of this story
and I won't lie to you again but here's
what really happened I was sitting in
the courtyard looking like [ __ ] that's
true and the guy was looking at me but
then the rest of it I just made up in my
head just this is an angry hateful rich
dick you probably want to kick me out
and then here's what I would say I would
say these three really cool things right
in a row and of course he set me up for
all them because I'm him too it's kind
of hard to lose an argument when you're
both people and it's taking place in
your brain and then in reality he really
did come up to me and he said are you
new to the building and I said yeah I
just moved here and he said oh welcome
he was so nice he was incredibly nice
and he's been for the last years my
favorite person in the world he's George
my neighbor children he's probably
watching I love George he's the greatest
well son I like I don't like I should
just scared hostages throws people don't
know what an ostrich is it's a big-ass
bird that's the same size as me
he's birds are huge okay I'm in Nebraska
doing the show in Nebraska I had to pee
so I'm one side of road I'm peeing right
I get dumped in I look to my left it's a
big-ass ostrich looking at me while I'm
peeing he was standing on one leg like
this
his body was facing this way but it's
here he's here now I didn't know what it
was so I didn't say anything my friend
got the car he's like yell was that as I
don't know it's like a big ass man
pigeon I don't know I don't know what is
right I don't know man pigeon I was like
any other man pigeon he took a pin hit
through ink pen and all right Susie dude
pin at it hit the oxygen chest Susie at
the ostriches other lady came down his
body was still facing this right but his
head it was still like this now when it
when his leg came down this is when the
[ __ ] started to come out of me a little
bit I was like you know what we should
um we should we should probably go get
back in the car because because we don't
really know what that mean you mean like
that that could be a sign that you mean
like you got ten seconds to get the [ __ ]
out my face before I kill you I may eat
you kids we don't we don't know what
he's trying to say so let's get back in
the car we say fast so we get in the car
soon as we get in the car I start
laughing on my you're a [ __ ] to me like
no you're a [ __ ] no you're a [ __ ]
I'm laughing I'm driving like thirty
miles an hour I look out the pageant
window the ostrich was running 30 miles
per hour beside the car his body was
still facing this way
[Applause]
he was Hall answer at 30 miles an hour
now when I'm scared like if I'm real
real scared I get emotional I'll start
to cry if I'm real scared so I got a
little emotional you know I looked at my
friend I was like why would you why
would you throw a pin at it if we if we
don't even know what it is
no no no I'm not saying that I'm saying
like I'm saying we don't even know what
it is like dude stop bitching speed up
speed up I lied to you tonight I started
driving like 60 miles per hour when I
tell y'all that this ostrich was running
60 miles per hour
I'm not bullshitting his body was still
facing this way but his here we still
like this he was running so you couldn't
even see his legs he was going so
[ __ ] fans he's he was moving and the
reason why I was so scared is because he
never looked in front of him like he
didn't care about a wall another ostrich
he was just looking at us but the way he
was looking at it's like he was saying
when I catch y'all I'm a [ __ ] both y'all
up over a penny over I got damn pain and
I was like why don't you just apologize
you know I'm saying I
because I didn't throw the pen I was
scared that's the only time I [ __ ] on
myself in my life I've never seen myself
but I let go that time I let loose you
got to make life interesting like that
because it [ __ ] is flimsy life is flimsy
you think you're gonna live it's
dangerous out here we know what's going
on I travel now you know I just think DC
had the roughest ghettos in the country
no no I have seen some [ __ ] now oh
there's some rough rough areas outside
of DC yeah everybody should go to the
ghetto I was taking it again at one time
that's the worst when you get taking it
you're not expecting to go right usually
you want to know where you're gonna get
her like I'm gonna see some loud [ __ ] I
got to prepare myself I'm gonna see some
crazy when you're taking is different
I had a limousine driver it was after
shows late at night it's like 3:00 in
the morning had a limousine driver he's
a nice guy talking to me and [ __ ] oh are
you from down DC weren't that's a rough
City man and his cell phone started
ringing hold on one second hello
Oh what what the [ __ ] slow my way
I gotta make a stop real quick at 3
o'clock in the morning I didn't know he
was telling me to get away first gun
store gun store look at stalking me
sound look good
he didn't say [ __ ] just pulled up in
from an old rickety building that looked
like a project ma'am
I never been there before I'm not sure
if it was a project but it certainly had
all the familial symptoms of a project
[ __ ] crackhead ran this way
and then another one jumped out of tree
and she just
but I said I'd be right back left me
took the keys with me just let me at 3
o'clock in the morning in front of a
project and a [ __ ] limousine this was
not good I was like man I gotta look
around see if I can see some landmarks
and figure out where I'm at I have to
escape on foot
that isn't one I know I was in a bad
neighborhood you only see this in the
worst neighborhoods remember it's three
o'clock in the morning it's three
o'clock in the morning I look out the
window it was a [ __ ] baby standing on
the corner
and the baby the baby they need to look
scary just on it
I mean it made me sad it made me sad
really good because I wanted to help the
baby I don't trust you either I'm sorry
but the old baby on the corner trick
we're not gonna fall for that [ __ ]
where's this limousine driving I stopped
feeling bad it's time goes by stop
feeling worse I mean what is wrong with
me what the hell is wrong I'm scared of
a baby this baby could be in trouble he
might need my help I got to do something
but I wasn't gonna get out the car I'm
serious man I just crack the window a
little bit there's a whole limousine I
can roll it down
[Applause]
hey baby baby doll man stricken with a
[ __ ] daughter
the babies and I'm selling weed [ __ ]
at all
[Music]
I'm sorry I had to buy two bags from the
coma
now back in the car rolled me a joint
Lancer
that [ __ ] was scary man every once in a
while like a crack here will come up to
the car and look in the windows like
Jurassic Park and should you be looking
on the car
hey get out of here cracking that baby
that's not feeling bad again yeah we
make you feel guilty sometimes oh man
what is wrong with me man I have just
bought weed from from an infant I can't
condone this kind of behavior what am I
thinking I can't let the fear ruin my
morals got to do something hey baby stop
selling weed all right you got your
whole life ahead of you you say [ __ ] you
[ __ ] here's the feed
[Applause]